الرئيس بايدن، شيء
قاله المستشار الخاص في تقريره هو أن
أحد أسباب عدم توجيه التهم إليك هو
أنه في وصفه أنت
رجل مسن حسن النية وذو
ذاكرة ضعيفة، أنا حسن النية وأنا
رجل مسن  وأنا أعلم ماذا
أفعل بحق الجحيم، لقد كنت رئيسًا، وأعدت هذا
البلد للوقوف على قدميه مرة أخرى، ولست بحاجة إلى
توصيته، فمدى سوء
ذاكرتك تمامًا، وهل يمكنك الاستمرار
كرئيس، ذاكرتي سيئة للغاية، وأسمح بذلك  أنت
تتحدث، وهذا هو أن
ذاكرتك أصبحت
أسوأ سيدي الرئيس، ذاكرتي ليست
ذاكرتي جيدة لعدة أشهر عندما
سُئلت عن عمرك كنت سترد
بالكلمات شاهدني، لقد كان الكثير من
الأمريكيين يشاهدونني وقد
عبروا عن مخاوفهم بشأن عمرك  هذا
هو حكمك، وهذا هو حكمك،
وهو ليس حكم الصحافة كما
تعلم في البداية،
لم يرغب رئيس المكسيك CCE في فتح البوابة للسماح
بدخول المواد الإنسانية،
تحدثت معه وأقنعته بفتح الباب.
بوابة
المكسيك المكسيك من أين جاء ذلك،
أعني أن هذا هو الشيء الوحيد الذي
سيتذكره أي شخص من هذا، كما تعلم أنه
تمت تبرئته هنا وأعتقد
أنه من السهل أن تتم تبرئته
وأعتقد أنه من الناحية القانونية لم يواجه أي
مشكلة مع هذا  لأن قضية
النية الإجرامية كانت غائبة بشكل واضح
في قضية بايدن